le département de la réunion présente
son projet de budget primitif pour
l'année 2020 un projet engagé et
ambitieux disposant de nouvelles marges
de manoeuvre obtenu grâce à une
stratégie innovante
le budget primitif 2020 s'inscrit
conformément aux orientations
budgétaires dans une trajectoire
écologique et solidaire en s'accordant à
développer encore plus les politiques
d'action sociale de développement du
territoire et de solidarité écologique
[Musique]
le budget primitif du département pour
l'année 2020 s'élève à 1 milliard 96
millions cinq cent quarante quatre mille
euros
à périmètre constant le budget 2020 est
en augmentation de 60 millions d'euros
par rapport à 2019 un budget maîtrisé
d'une part avec une stabilité de son
endettement
sur les trois dernières années preuve
également de la santé financière du
département une progression du niveau
d'épargné brute qui atteint les 80 5,7
millions d'euros cette progression de
l'épargné va permettre au département
d'accroître son niveau d'investissement
en 2020 avec un volume de crédits de
160,5 millions d'euros un budget
maîtrisé qui ne prévoit aucune hausse de
la fiscalité pour 2020 et qui engage les
actions départementales au plus près des
réunions
[Musique]
la mission budgétaire soutien à
l'autonomie à tous les âges de la vie
est l'un des postes les plus importants
en termes de dépenses cette mission
prend principalement en charge les
allocations individuelles de solidarité
et les dispositifs d'inclusion sociale
pour nos gramounes comme l'emaf le
transport des personnes à mobilité
réduite et les places ouvertes dans les
établissements sociaux et médico-sociaux
[Musique]
la mission insertion emploi logement et
coopération est doté au budget primitif
d'un montant global de 72 millions
d'euros cette mission vise à développer
et à mettre en action des mesures
d'insertion professionnelle en faveur
des bénéficiaires des minima sociaux
grâce à la recentralisation du rsa le
département met en place un dispositif
innovant d'incitation à la reprise d'une
activité professionnelle en faveur des
bénéficiaires du rsa pour un montant
global de 7 millions d'euros les crédits
soutiendront l'insertion par l'activité
économique et par le secteur marchand
les actions de lutte contre l'habitat
indigne et l'accessibilité des personnes
à mobilité réduite seront soutenus pour
répondre à plus de 2000 ménages en
situation de fragilité
[Musique]
près de 119 millions d'euros seront
consacrés à la mission protection de
l'enfance et de la famille au coeur de
ce dispositif
la prévention des ruptures familiales
avec le financement des maisons
d'enfants à caractère social et les
services d'action éducative en milieu
ouvert
le département s'engage dans la
protection de la santé des parents et
des enfants de moins de 6 ans au sein de
ses centres de protection maternelle et
infantile
une autre action essentielle délégué au
département la protection et la garantie
de prise en charge des mineurs confiés à
l'aide sociale à l'enfance
[Musique]
les crédits dédiés à la mission
promotion de la culture et des sports
s'élève à près de 11 millions d'euros un
budget en faveur du rayonnement du monde
artistique des manifestations
culturelles des activités scientifiques
et éducatives des crédits
d'investissement seront également
consacrés à la restauration et à la
valorisation du patrimoine départemental
pour privilégier l'accueil des visiteurs
dans des conditions optimales
les crédits prévus en 2020 au titre de
la mission épanouissement de la jeunesse
s'élève à 59 5 millions d'euros un
financement nécessaire au fonctionnement
et à l'équipement des 83 collèges de
l'île et des soixante mille collégiens
réunionnais et crédits sont maintenues
pour accompagner les étudiants en
formation initiale à la réunion et en
mobilité
près de deux millions d'euros seront
investis dans le programme insertion
socioprofessionnelle des jeunes
les crédits de la mission développement
de l'agriculture et de l'eau s'élève à
plus de 33 millions d'euros une
enveloppe consacrée au soutien aux
agriculteurs pour une agriculture
diversifiée la protection du foncier
agricole et la mise en oeuvre du plan
agrippé l'extension des périmètres
irrigués la structuration des
équipements hydrauliques et le contrôle
sanitaire des eaux sont également
financés à hauteur de 18 millions
d'euros
[Musique]
les crédits est relatif à la mission
route et aménagement de l'espace public
s'élève à plus de 55 millions d'euros 30
millions d'euros seront consacrés à
l'entretien et à l'amélioration des
routes départementales le département
maintiendra en 2020 ces actions de
proximité en faveur des communes au
travers des pacte de solidarité
territoriale
les crédits de la mission environnement
tourisme et aménagement des eaux s'élève
à près de 21 millions d'euros
cette mission s'engage dans la
protection et l'aménagement des espaces
naturels et forestier l'objectif en 2020
et de restaurer 700 hectares d'espacés
naturels l'aménagement et le
développement écotouristique du
territoire font également partie de
cette compétence
les dépenses d'administration générale
du département sont en hausse de 14
millions d'euros dont 11,5 sont
consacrés à la modernisation
territoriale des services à
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
et à la transition écologique le
financement des ressources humaines et
maîtrisée avec une évolution de 0 7% du
fait de la stabilisation des effectifs
départementaux
le projet de budget primitif 2020 et le
premier budget post recentralisation du
rsa ainsi le département peut accroître
ses interventions de plus de 60 millions
d'euros en 2020 cela permettra de donner
une nouvelle impulsion à ces politiques
sociales et notamment de mener une
expérimentation innovante en faveur du
retour à l'emploi des bénéficiaires du
rsa le département reprendre a toute sa
place dans l'accompagnement humain
économique environnemental et social à
la réunion